claire hattrick would like to go back on
hrt to ease menopausal joint pain but
doesn't want to start medication she
can't be sure she can continue
she says some women are traveling miles
to source hrt but limiting some
prescriptions to three months to tackle
supply issues is too little too late
i know women
in my group they're messaging me
constantly on clipboard claire you know
i can't get hold of my hrt i'm cutting
patches in half you know women are
trading drugs in car parks and i think
women are that desperate they do
whatever it takes i think they would pay
through the nose for it which is not
it's not acceptable women shouldn't have
to be buying off the black market and
then you've got the worry is do you
really know what you're taking
hrt can help alleviate severe menopause
symptoms including hot flushes night
sweats and anxiety
but of the treatments the government
wants to restrict this birmingham
pharmacist told us two are not available
and one has limited supply you have to
say i'm sorry but i can't get hold of
this you know or if they bring in a
person we have to check on a daily basis
so if they come in with a prescription i
have to tell them wait here let me check
the stock levels before you leave you
know because i just don't want you to
you know leave a prescription here
expect that i'm going to fill it for you
lynn robinson is the lead consultant at
birmingham women's hospital for
menopause and fertility and is also on
the medical advisory council for the
british menopause society she says there
needs to be longer-term solutions the
department of health and social care
have previously allowed pharmacists to
prescribe to change their prescriptions
to something equivalent if
whatever the gp or doctor's prescribed
isn't in stock
and um
do you think that will solve the problem
it's not solve the problem but it'll
make things easier the government says
it's listening to women's concerns and
will do everything in its power to
increase access to hrt but campaigners
say supply is outstripping demand after
an explosion in the use of hrt by women
struggling with the menopause lisa
holland sky news